start with saying wow that was quite a  finish to this game  yeah i mean it was an awful game but  i got the result i needed so now i need  one more  how much does the whole stoppage uh  matter to the outcome here i i don't  know i thought it would be huge negative  for me because he was clearly losing the  threat uh  and the position was very tough for him  but i don't know he blundered  immediately afterwards so  that was super rage like  uh position was  very difficult for him but probably  still holdable and then he just lost it  in one move with h7 which is crazy  that's that's the way it is you're still  punching  ah i don't know um  somewhat alive materialist  good luck